il y a de plus en plus de personnes
âgées de plus en plus âgées et de plus
en plus de gens en grande précarité il
faut imaginer des solutions on ne pourra
pas continuer comme ça
vous avez fait scandale en publiant
médecin chef à la prison de la Santé une
description sans concession de la vie
quotidienne dans un établissement
pénitentiaire ça a été un véritable choc
après le livre en 2000 vous avez encore
passé neuf mois à la prison de la Santé
ça pas été facile j'imagine non non ça
n'a pas été facile du tout du tout j'ai
eu des menaces de mort ma moto a été
saccagée
il y a eu des essais de l'être
diffamatoires contre moi non c'est pas
marrant et quand vous avez été libéré
vous aviez perdu 5 kilos et vous dites
j'avais l'impression de sortir d'une
machine à essorage rapide
c'est un bon plan pour maigrir ça c'est
vrai et j'étais complètement
complètement ébervé oui alors à ce
moment-là vous partez à l'hôpital
Pompidou dans un service qui s'occupe
des toxicos 15 jours plus tard vous
savez déjà que que vous resterez pas et
vous tenez six mois vous dites je ne
suis pas une fanatique du dévouement
sans retour ni merci
c'est à dire que là les toxico que vous
aviez à l'hôpital Pompidou j'ai aucune
envie de s'en sortir
et donc c'est un éternel recommencement
et
c'est vrai que il y a pas enfin pour moi
moi ça ça ne convenait pas si je peux me
permettre
il y a pas de docteur
si tu as envie d'arrêter tu arrêtes
il y a aucun docteur aucun psychiatre
aucun il y a personne qui peut te faire
arrêter si toi tu as décidé d'arrêter tu
arrêtes
si toi dans ta tête t'as pas décidé
d'arrêter d'être à jamais arrête
toi aussi
ensuite vous partez à l'hôpital
Saint-Antoine et vous publiez
aujourd'hui chez Flammarion votre
journal de bord qui s'appelle l'hôpital
en danger vous dites l'hôpital est
devenu un hospice il est encombré par
des gens qui n'ont pas être là des SDF
des grabataires des cas sociaux tous les
on est là pour les soignants mais une
fois qu'ils sont guéris il faut trouver
il faut trouver des structures pour les
pour les mettre tous les laisser pour
qu'on de la société qui aujourd'hui se
retrouvent à l'hôpital c'est ça et
l'hôpital sera tout c'est à dire que
aussi bien on va les acheter des des
chaussures sur le faubourg Saint-Antoine
ils ont pas il faut il faut les habiller
il faut trouver un logement faut trouver
des solutions pour tout donc c'est très
lourd ils prennent la place des vrais
malades en plus dans cette hôtellerie
assistée il y en a qui reste jusqu'à
deux ans et
au frais de la sécurité sociale et c'est
vrai qu'il y a des malades qui attendent
parce qu'il y a il y a de plus en plus
de de
d'attente à l'hôpital
en plus vous dites que ça coûte dans 7
euros par jour c'est le service le moins
cher donc ça veut dire qu'il y a des
gens qui sont là qui n'ont pas être à
l'hôpital qui prennent des places qui
coûtent 507 euros par jour la sécurité
sociale alors qu'il pourrait être dans
des hospices ça existe ça existe en
Suède dans des hôtels qui sont tenus par
des infirmières ça peut être il faut
imaginer des solutions il y a de plus en
plus de personnes âgées de plus en plus
âgées et de plus en plus de gens en
grande précarité il faut imaginer des
solutions on pourra pas continuer comme
ça
alors vous racontez la détresse la
misère c'est terrible son bouquin
vraiment c'est un une descente aux
enfers des familles
ingrates que l'hôpital remplace vous
racontez l'histoire d'une fille à qui
vous apprenez que finalement sa mère
n'est pas morte et qui dit qu'est-ce
qu'on va en faire
des anecdotes comme ça il y en a plein
de bouquins c'est
quelqu'un qui laisse une sa vieille
maman aux urgences et qui met personne à
prévenir en cas d'urgence les pompes
funèbres on sait c'est quand même
on abandonne les petits vieux au moment
des vacances pour partir en vacances on
les abandonne aux urgences voilà à vous
raconter la décriture des vieux
justement cette dame qui a un scorbut
qui qui est très avancé puisque on voit
l'os de ces jambes et vous dites qu'en
fait c'est parce qu'elle se nourrit de
conserve et de gâteau sec quoi c'est à
dire qu'en fait oui je savais pas moi en
arrivant à l'hôpital que le scorbut
était si répandu chez les personnes
âgées il y a eu des
déviés une vieille de vieilles dames qui
sont arrivées mortes de faim qui ont été
sauvés en ayant juste à manger à boire
il y a beaucoup de petits vieux qui
arrivent complètement dénutri il faut
savoir qu'en plein Paris il y a des
petits vieux qui vivent dans des
conditions moyenâgeuses
sans rien
c'est moi ça m'a beaucoup choquée parce
que je ne le savais pas et c'est vrai
que quand il y a eu la canicule en 2003
on n'a pas été étonné à l'hôpital parce
qu'il y a un abandon total
vous rencontrer des scènes terribles
l'oeil qui reste dans la compresse ça
c'est un truc sur quelqu'un ah oui mais
l'hôpital c'est ça à l'hôpital c'est
aussi beaucoup de
c'est terrible l'hôpital
c'est dur et moi je je ne veux pas me
protéger de la souffrance je ne veux pas
me blinder je ne veux pas être un
technicien de la santé et j'en prends
plein la tronche et
bon c'est comme ça c'est ma façon moi de
d'accompagner les gens
alors vous raconter aussi l'acharnement
thérapeutique que vous qualifiez de
torture légale vous parlez d'une dame de
89 ans qui pèse 30 kg qui a un cancer du
foie au stade terminal oui oui c'était
une vieille dame qui était sourd et
muette et donc
elle communiquait que par une ardoise et
ça a été terrible parce que il a fallu
lui dire qu'elle avait une maladie grave
tout ça sur une ardoise vous imaginez
et quand on a voulu l'envoyer dans une
structure de de soins palliatifs
le mari nous a traité tous les noms et
c'est après j'ai appris par les
infirmières que en fait son mari la
torturel lui avait cassé les dents un
coup de marteau lui avait tapé dans le
ventre il y a beaucoup de femmes battues
il y a aussi une ponction lombaire qu'on
fait un homme de 88 ans quoi c'est à
dire que ça sert à rien de le faire
souffrir parce qu'en plus il est il est
dans une phase terminale oui mais il y a
beaucoup d'exemples comme ça enfin moi
j'étais très frappé par
les médecins ne réfléchissent pas ne
veulent pas réfléchir ils sont dans la
technique médicale et pour eux c'est un
moyen de se protéger comme ça ils ont
pas posé la bonne question
moi j'ai eu beaucoup de discussions avec
avec les médecins parce que moi je pense
que que
la compassion c'est d'accompagner
quelqu'un jusqu'à la fin et le mieux
possible en le respectant et c'était
notamment un catholique intégriste
qui m'avait dit que c'était pas dans sa
religion et moi je pense qu'au contraire
au contraire le message du christianisme
c'est bien ça c'est de d'accompagner
l'autre
vous avez raison dans son respect et
c'est pas justement de s'acharner comme
ça mais ça c'est pour pas se poser la
question vous avez raison alors au-delà
de ces cas terrible vous raconter le
quotidien courte linasque de l'hôpital
par exemple à Noël il y a pas de
mammographie pendant trois semaines
parce que voilà bah les gens sont en
vacances c'est fermé on peut pas faire
de mammographie pendant trois semaines
un labo par exemple faut trois semaines
pour avoir une biopsie d'un ganglion
donc le mec en trois semaines ça le
temps de s'aggraver
énormément énormément de demandes et
on n'arrive pas à suivre on n'arrive pas
à suivre et puis il y a les pannes
d'ascenseur les vitres sales les mégots
par terre enfin le pire moi ce qui m'a
le plus étonné c'est les vols
c'est-à-dire que la nuit on vous on vous
a piqué votre stéthoscope on pique des
dictionnaires médicaux enfin en plus il
y a des vols
permanents mais dans les bureaux on
pique les ordinateurs les imprimantes
les médecins ils préfèrent les beaux
malades ceux sur lesquels on peut
publier finalement donc il y a toute une
partie des malades qui les intéresse pas
justement ils deviennent techniciens de
la santé on a on a oublié la part
d'humanisme
alors il est querelles fratricide en
plus entre les médecins vous dites qu'il
y a aucun esprit d'équipe enfin si
chacun pour sa gueule quoi l'esprit du
médecin
hospitalier
c'est c'est le oui c'est de
se faire valoir dans votre bouquin c'est
la visite du ministre Douste Blazy quand
il arrive au milieu de tout ça quoi il
était là avec des caméras de télé
pour dire que les lits restaient ouvert
bon c'est bien mais si les lits restent
ouverts et qui a une canicule ou un
autre problème grave l'afflumative des
malades à partir du moment où les lits
sont tous ouverts dans tout se plaint
parce qu'il y a jamais un lit qui reste
vide plus de trois heures c'est ça me
paraît tout à fait débile il y a un
malade qui s'appelle la mascotte qui a
déjà coûté 210 000 euros à la sécurité
sociale la mascotte est resté deux ans
il y a eu avant d'autres mascottes et de
nouveaux il y a des mascottes et ça ce
sont des des personnes qui sont qui sont
pas assez âgées pour aller dans des
structures pour les gens âgées et qui
ont le cerveau démoli et qui ne sont
plus autonomes et je sais pas où mettre
je me demande moi si vous n'êtes pas un
médecin malgré vous finalement parce que
on sent bien que ça vous a insupportable
est-ce que vous allez continuer
longtemps faire ça maintenant je fais je
suis en consultation donc les gens
arrivent debout
ils s'en vont debout donc Véronique
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire contre cet
hôpital qui fait pas son boulot
créer des structures d'aval pour les
pour les SDF qui ont besoin de soins il
y a le Samu social mais il est
complètement débordé et on arrive jamais
à voir de place créer des déstructures
plus de place dans des maisons pour les
personnes âgées beaucoup plus la
population vieillit il y a de plus en
plus de gens âgés et de plus en plus de
gens très âgés
tu vois à quel point c'est c'est concret
il y a rien non mais tu peux dire que la
dame elle est jolie qu'elle est bien
habillée
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inarritube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu